if you've ever been with an earshot of a
spanish soccer broadcast you've probably
heard this yet
[Music]
[Applause]
the reflexive pulse-pounding howl that
either lifts your spirits or drags it
down
it brings out a lot of emotion because
it's the most important and perhaps
decisive play of the game the goal call
is an undeniable staple of soccer and no
one knows this more than telemundo
play-by-play announcer andres contour
this is the story of the voice that took
the us by storm
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
decades before contour even got close to
a mic he was living in argentina looking
for a big break on the pitch
i actually
wanted to
play soccer professionally i tried out
in the minor leagues then i came to the
us played high school played college and
the joke is that here in the u.s the
professional league wasn't around so i
didn't have anywhere to go and i decided
to do the next best thing which is
broadcasting fast forward a few years
later i got a call for an audition they
asked me to do play-by-play contours
lively commentary was infectious i'm
really really passionate about soccer
and i think that transcends into my
broadcast and they hired me within 48
hours
[Music]
as contour did more and more broadcasts
soccer was becoming mainstream in the us
hitting a fever pitch in 1994 when it
hosted the world cup
i had the opportunity of calling all
matches of the world cup and that
created a lot of pressure on myself
but kantor never buckled under the
pressure and started attracting new fans
and i remember that after the first
couple of games my work started getting
attention
the way he called the games was unlike
anything many english-speaking americans
had heard before especially when someone
scored
basically in latin america we
always have called the gold coal
the same way here in the us i just was
very lucky to be in a position where i
helped popularize a little bit the game
through my broadcast
though contour didn't invent the gold
battle cry he certainly perfected it and
soccer fans old and new alike couldn't
get enough please welcome univision's
andres cantor andre
i was very fortunate after 1994 that you
know my career received so much
attention
[Applause]
i started doing many endorsements for
different companies and had cameo
appearances and television shows
i have no control
this job has taken its toll
[Music]
but despite these opportunities contour
hasn't lost sight of why he's still
doing this 30 years later i mean soccer
has been my life since
i can remember really i really
feel very passionate about the game and
i bring on that passion from the minute
the whistle blows to the end of the game
[Music]
you